[музика]
Привіт друзі з вами сьогодні пані Соля і
наш друг як його звати
Совеня молодці але степеня знову немає з
нами Тож давайте ми його погукаємо Ану
друзі підготували ручки і гукаємо Совеня
і ще раз Совеня де ти Соня летиш до нас
чи не летиш ви чули чули чу ой друзі Я
Втік від такого грому і блискавки
змок але з тих до вас на заняттях
ви знаєте про що ми сьогодні будемо
говорити Я думаю Совеня точно знає тому
що він що не нам дав підказку про що ми
говоритимемо а будемо ми говорити про
Грім та блискавку правильно
друзі
як утворюється Грім та блискавка і
взагалі чому ми спершу бачимо блискавку
а грім неначе добігає Через декілька
секунд Цікаво чому так відбувається і
зараз ми з вами дізнаємося Отож
перш за все Скажіть будь ласка чи ви
любите коли гримить і блискає
я от наприклад не дуже люблю бо це дуже
гучно І знаєте так зразу погоди така
погана і холодно може бути Я люблю коли
світить сонечко Що ж відбувається коли
ми чуємо і бачимо Грім та блискавку перш
за все Грім та блискавка відбувається
коли у нас є така спеціальна погода а
особливо коли на неї з'являються яких
марки пригадуєте ми з вами раніше вчили
купчасто-дощові молодці І коли ти хмарок
стає дуже багато вони сходяться одна
біля одної одна біля одної
малесенький краплинки води Які стають
кристаликами і які є у хмарках
починають тертися між собою це
називається сила тертя і відповідно
тертя цих маленьких частинок хмарок між
собою надає на
маленьким кристаликам особливого заряду
і після цього нас відбувається Блискавка
та грім як ми можемо це наприклад
перевірити що таке є тертя І що таке
особливий електричний заряд Якщо у вас є
повітряна кулька Івана наприклад потрати
нею біля голови але так сильно
сильно-сильно і поставити біля стіни Ось
так кульку тут в мене зараз не вийде
оскільки це не стіна а дошка то ви
побачите що кулька тримається на стіні
ця також є сила тертя та певний
електричний заряд
відповідно друзі
коли ми бачимо Грім та блискавку знайте
Це між собою
сперечаються змагаються різні маленькі
кристалики льоду і ми це називаємо
сталою тертя
чому
Спершу ми бачимо блискавку а тоді грім
невже це відбувається нарізно ні малюки
Грім і блискавка йдуть поруч
але через те що
блискавка це є світло А сила світла є
значно швидшою ніж сила звуку ми спершу
бачимо блискавку і аж через декілька
секунд Ми чуємо що щось гримить Ось так
друзі Ось така історія від пані солі і
совеняти
[музика]
Отож друзі зараз ми з вами пограємо у
гру дивіться будь ласка У нас є три
різні рядки
бачите тут у нас є сонечко веселка
хмарка
далі воно знов повторюється а тут у нас
є дві пусті клітинки і потрібно ці
клітинки заповнити тим що буде далі
допоможіть мені будь ласка Отож У нас є
сонце веселка хмарка
сонце веселка хмарка що має бути тут
друзі Ану уважно Гляньте і Допоможіть
мені
добре друзі сонце молодці а що після
сонця у нас де наступне
так малята
веселка бо якщо глянути на наш логічний
ряд
то після хмарки у нас зразу йде сонце
ось тут і ось тут а після сонця у нас
йде веселка і ми її бачимо тут а також
тут дуже добре наступна вправа
хмарки сонечком веселка сонечко хмарки
сонечком Веселка що тут має бути добре
сонечко А наступним після сонечка у нас
що йде
добре хмарки з сонечком і останнє це що
нас ще доповнює наш логічний ряд добре
друзі
веселка молодці Ану Нагадайте мені
скільки кольорів Я у веселки
добре сім молодці тепер останній ряд У
нас тут є
Грім і блискавка
сонце і хмарки дощик знову Грім і
блискавка що в нас тут має бути і ось
тут
молодці друзі Ми дивимося на перший наш
ряд після блискавки у нас де сонце і
хмарки відповідно тут після блискавки що
має бути добре друзі сонце і хмарки
і тут після сонця і хмарки У нас знову
дощик дуже добре молодці малюки я Без
вас би геть не впоралися Ви мені дуже
допомогли
Ось така історія на сьогодні Таке наше
заняття і вже наша свого дня висохло
правда Так мені вже геть геть не мокро я
вже собі тут загрівся біля вас з друзів
і мені було дуже цікаво дізнатися чому я
спершу бачу блискавку а потім чув грім
Ох Друзі Ну що ж будемо прощатися був
радий вас бачити до наступного разу
друзі па-па па-па
Привіт друзі Усім привіт з вами
науковець Соломія та навковиця Сьогодні
ми експериментуємо і Нам буде потрібно
дуже цікаві предмети трубочки дві
трубочки і картоплинка сира ми зараз
будемо Що робити Ми будемо пробувати
встромити
труби так соломинку у картопленку
соломинка картоплинка маємо такий віршик
А якщо пробувати ось такий спосіб дуже
часто трубочка Ну бачите ламається не
виходить в мене нічого тільки
картопельку Пони що але є один спосіб
завдяки якому можна встромити
трубочку в картоплинку так щоб вона не
згиналася А ось розкажу
треба закрити пальчиком
зверху трубочку
і якщо ми
запихаємо дивіться рівно залізна і
жодних зусиль не було витраченою
і соломинка є рівною Тобто вона не
погнулася бо ця як правило буде гнутися
воно бачите на рівно встає якось дуже
складно запхнути соломинку у картопельку
Як це працює Я розумію друзі що ми на
кожного дня запихаємо соломинки У
картопелька це якесь таке дуже цікаве
заняття але просто щоб ви знали як це
працює коли ми закриваємо пальчиком
трубочку ми перекриваємо доступ повітря
Так бо до повітря в трубочку заходить і
тут ми гоп закрили і повітря не виходить
і завдяки тому що повітря знаходиться у
трубочці трубочка і такою стійкішою
міцнішою і тому вона Значно краще
входить у картоплинку Тобто вона є
міцнішою одна навіть так якщо Ось так
робити то найімовірніше що
соломинка не буде згинатися
те саме так молодець і наша трубочка
Тоді стійкіша так ось так
от все
Ось так друзі дуже
молодець
вийшло так ось так ЗНО звати вже там
щось далі хотіла запхати так от і все
друзі ось такий в нас експеримент
всім па-па
[музика]